welcome back to CBS this morning this is
a look at workers removing the Johnny
Reb's statue this morning that sat on
top of an 80-foot Confederate Monument
in downtown Norfolk Virginia the mayor
says the statue will be relocated out of
concern for public safety protesters
across America are tearing down in
damaging memorials that they say honors
racist figures from history chip readers
in Richmond another Virginia City where
Confederate monuments are under a check
under attack rather chip good morning to
you I know this has been an issue there
for years Oh for a very long time of
course Richmond was the capital of the
Confederacy so there are monuments like
this one this one is to robert e lee all
over this town politicians have spent
years talking about doing something
about it maybe bringing them down
putting them in a museum or maybe just
adding some context but this week
protesters said we are tired of waiting
Richmond residents celebrated Thursday
at the graffiti covered and long
controversial statue of Confederate
General Robert E Lee there's hundreds of
years in the making
and all the emotion and all the energy
and all the passion that created that
would be ashamed to wipe that away very
empowering not just by should black
beautiful boy ku as well who once
changed that call for change has hit the
city's monuments hard with protesters
bringing down the statue of Jefferson
Davis the president of the Confederacy
and landing Christopher Columbus in a
local lake protesters took action across
the country tearing down memorials to
the country's racist history leading
some officials to demand permanent
removal American people know these names
have to go in Congress House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi is called to do away with
Confederate statues in the halls of the
Capitol met Republican resistance a
bipartisan proposal advanced in the
Senate would begin the process of
renaming about ten military bases that
honor Confederate officers President
Trump and some Republican allies spoke
out in opposition
of us was to erase from history erase
every person and name an event not
righteous enough and to cast those who
would object as defenders of the cause
of slavery why do we want to name or
venerate people who fought to enslave
other human beings that's all we're
saying
Alicia Brooks at the Southern Poverty
Law Center has helped identify more than
1,700 Confederate symbols still standing
across the country and argues their
removal is a powerful symbol it's an
opportunity for us to move forward and
show members of the african-american
community we hear you we understand
we're doing something to be actively
anti-racist we've struggled to deal with
this country's tortured racial history
the University of Richmond professor
Julien hater advised Virginia to remove
the memorials we only generally tend to
come around and discuss the this
country's racial problems in instances
where there's trauma involved if perhaps
we might not be here if we were willing
to have these discussions when things
seem to be going normally the Southern
Poverty Law Center says about 140
Confederate symbols have been removed
since 2016 and Anthony that pace is now
accelerating greatly yeah the momentum
is building chip you mentioned in your
piece the push to rename military bases
around the country that are named for
Confederate war heros where does that
stand and why right now well I tell you
why because of so much that is going on
right now but this is really surprising
it is really gaining some steam and the
idea has been around for a very long
time it's being pushed primarily by
Elizabeth Warren Liberal Democrat of
Massachusetts you might think
Republicans aren't going to agree with
that but Republicans on the key Senate
committee have already said they'll go
along error are a couple of opponents
but it appears to be moving ahead this
effort would rename ten military bases
take a look at them they include Ford
Bennett Fort Benning in Georgia Fort
Hood in Texas and Fort Bragg in North
Carolina some very prominent bases now
the Democrats
how strongly favorite they say after all
these men took up arms against the
United States in favor of slavery a big
but though President Trump has said he
will veto any effort to do this all
right chip Reed in Richmond Virginia
Thank You chip